hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're gonna be doing an updated
look and what I've been recently using
to vlog with any time I post vlogs I see
you guys in the comments asking the same
questions over and over again what am i
filming with what kind of lenses am i
using what microphone what tripod all of
those questions I will answer today in
this video a huge thank you to
Skillshare for sponsoring today's video
if you guys haven't heard about
Skillshare definitely check it out if
you're like me I have pretty much
learned everything I know when it comes
to video production and editing and
taking photos anytime I have a question
or anything I'm always going to the
internet to look up stuff so Skillshare
has over 17,000 classes and courses that
you guys can take ranging from a variety
of subjects creative business technology
I was so excited because one of the
things that I've always wanted to learn
is how to take better photos at night
this is one of the first courses that I
came across they have so many things so
whatever it is that you're looking to
learn I guarantee that they will have
something there for you if you guys want
to check it out the first 500 people to
click my link and sign up in the
description below will get Premium
Membership for 99 cents for two months
and then after that it's $10 a month if
you choose to continue all of the
courses are taught by people who are
experts in their field and this is also
pretty awesome too I travel a lot and
sometimes I don't always have an
internet connection you can download
them on your iPhone or your Android
phone so if you are offline you can
still view the courses so I don't want
to overwhelm you guys but let me go
through all of the stuff that I have
here first starting with the camera I
have two cameras that are my go-to for
vlogging this one is a little point and
shoot and this is the Sony rx100 Mark 5
I've talked about this camera many many
times I love this little thing but the
only downfall is it doesn't have an
audio input so that's where this one
comes in this is the Sony a 65 hundred
so what I'm filming this video with is
the sony a7s to you and you the biggest
difference is the sony a6000 is not a
full-frame sensor so with this i can use
smaller lenses it's much lighter
whereas the a7 s2 which I used to vlog
with is a full-frame the lenses are so
much heavier and it's also much more
expensive so what I'm traveling and I'm
carrying around this camera a lot of bad
things happen I've dropped it so many
times it's always hitting off of things
so I definitely feel a little bit better
about pairing this around because it is
way less expensive than the a7s2 and all
of the lenses that go with it so I just
recently got this lens and it's a kit
lens it's also a power zoom lens
it has this little zoom button right
here so it'll allow you to get some very
steady smooth zooms where all of the
lenses that I was using before to vlog
with were the manual kind so you have to
actually turn it to zoom so what I love
about this current setup is this camera
is now super light the sixteen
millimeter it gives you enough
wide-angle of a lens so that if you are
vlogging and filming yourself you can
entirely be in frame but it also has the
50 millimeter zoom so if there is
something happening in the distance
you'll be able to actually see it and
zoom in on it the two lenses that I was
using previously was this one I still
really like this lens but I do like the
look of this one a lot more because it
is a lot clearer and I can zoom a little
bit more because this is the 10 to 18 it
gives you a much wider field of view
when you're filming yourself so if you
do want that kind of wide angle lens
view and this is the lens for you I've
been using this lens for the past couple
of years so any of the vlogs that I've
shot with a 6500 there's a really good
chance that this is the one that I was
using and the zoom lens that I was using
before is a 16 to 70 I recently went to
Austria so I'm going to show you a
little bit of footage that I shot using
this lens and this lens I had the
absolute best time in Austria everyone
was so nice it was so lovely to meet so
many of you guys so here's an example of
using the wide-angle lens as you can see
you can get a little bit of zoom but not
very much but the wide-angle is so
perfect for vlogging and here we have an
example of what the 16 to 70 looks like
I'm able to really zoom in on the
animals and it looks pretty good so you
may be questioning right now Justine why
don't you just stick with these two
lenses and that's a very very valid
question I love these lenses there is
absolutely nothing wrong with these but
I was trying to find something that was
smaller and lighter and a little bit
more versatile which leads me to a next
lens that I got I watched so many
reviews on these lenses before I got
them this is an 18 to 105 which means
the 18 is a little bit zoomed in but if
you hold it out far enough you can still
get your full self in the frame to go
from an 18 through a 105 in a single
lens is incredible so I feel like the
next time I go to the zoo this is gonna
be the winner it's just so hard to be
able to be prepared for any situation a
lot of times you're gonna be filming
yourself but a lot of times something is
going to be happening off in the
distance and you're gonna want to
capture that so let's pop this lens back
on
so this lens is also a power zoom and
I'm getting really into the power zoom
especially if you're vlogging maybe if
you're a filmmaker or I don't know I've
read a lot of reviews where people are
not power zoom fans but I am now a huge
fan of it so you're able to zoom in and
out like this so as you can see all of
the zoom is happening internally inside
of this lens vlogging is its own sort of
strange art form because you have to be
ready for anything you don't have time
to sometimes set up specific settings so
when you're shooting a movie or a film
or a documentary or whatever it is that
you're filming your professional
cinematographer sometimes vlogging the
way that we do it completely throws
people off because they're like what are
you doing this isn't how you do it and I
say oh no no no this is how we do it
maybe not how you do it I also get a lot
of questions about this little
microphone I'll put a link in the
description to everything that I talk
about all of the cameras and the lenses
but this microphone I really like as
well it's very small and it sounds
really great it uses the Sony hotshoe so
you don't need to power it with anything
the camera itself powers the microphone
that's one of the problems that I always
ran into is I would use the rode
microphones and the batteries would
always be dead because I would leave it
on and always forget to turn it off and
then sometimes I would forget to turn it
on and then I have no audio on my video
so having this hotshoe microphone has
been such a lifesaver
honestly if there is one lens that
you're gonna get I do recommend this one
so much it's so small it looks like a
tiny little pancake it's also a very
inexpensive lens and some of the reviews
that I read is that it's not the best
quality lens but for what it is it's
pretty great for exactly what I need it
for now I'm gonna take you guys out on a
hike where I test it out to these two
new lenses I would love to hear what you
guys think of them so let's go outside
so now Aldona hayek testing out these
lenses Nick is over there he's got
another camera so he's basically gonna
be filming me filming myself and then
filming other things so the first ones
that I'm testing out is the sixteen to
fifty really excited about this lens cuz
it's really light so if you're kind of
on the go in a hurry this lens is
perfect but there is one downfall that
I've seen because this lens is one of
the powers and lenses if you try to
manually zoom in and out you can hear
the grinding of the motors so you guys
can hear how loud this lens is
so instead you can use this little
powers in button and it alleviates a lot
of that sound this is really riveting
content how far we gonne point two miles
point two miles oh I guess it's time for
a slow-mo montage with this lens
[Music]
okay so should we do a lens change all
right let's put on that 18 to 105 so
this is what the lens looks like if I'm
vlogging with it it is much heavier than
the little 16 to 50 lens but this is
definitely lighter than when I used to
vlog with my a7s2 because that camera in
comparison to the 6500 is a little bit
heavier and the lenses are much heavier
because it is a full-frame sensor so
with this one I can use smaller lenses
and really make it as light as possible
which is key for vlogging I would love
to vlog with the a7s2 or the a7 3-man
these lenses get so heavy I can't do it
[Music]
complain far cry right now
I don't really care if your mind I don't
need another side I'm wearing you down
to the girl I really don't care if you
online but I'm keeping you in the light
you really don't know which way to turn
you're always one step behind going down
this road again
[Music]
you grasp every crumb although although
you reach the
[Music]
[Applause]
you see
and nothing there
[Music]
so now I'm at the beach I wanted to test
these lenses out in a little bit of a
brighter condition because the hike that
I did was a little overcast so I want to
show you guys what it looks like on a
beautiful sunny day at the beach and it
is sunny but don't be deceived it's
actually freezing
freezing outside a little bit higher on
the feeling can't see to focus in the
corner
you were caring by some rum and cola
wasn't brave enough
[Music]
popped back on the 18 to 105 so let's
see how much I can get with the zoo
special
[Music]
and one last thing this is the tripod
that I use it is a tiny little tripod I
also love that this little mounts here
is movable although I think I'm ready
got some sand in it it's not moving as
well as it used to you can just attach
it on just like so there we go ready to
vlog thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and I
hope that you found something helpful
here even if you don't make videos this
is how I make videos
I'm so excited though because I just got
the a7 3 so I will be testing that out
very shortly
[Music]